space.com meldet eine merkwürdige
entdeckung auf dem mond demnach hat die
chinesische mondsonde chang'e ii 4 in
einem krater eine ungewöhnliche
gelartige substanz entdeckt das
forschungsteam hat daraufhin alle
planungen für den fortgang der mission
gestoppt und das material untersucht
krieg zum tanzen kritischen hier gibt's
täglich spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und activity glocke
nur dann verpasst ihr kein video los
geht's herzlich willkommen die ganze
mission ist sowieso schon mal eine
sensation zum ersten mal überhaupt ist
eine mondsonde auf der rückseite des
mondes gelandet der chinesische länder
g4 mit seinem mond rover youtube 2
bisher hatten es alle weltraum nationen
gescheut auf der rückseite zu landen
weil das mit deutlich erhöhtem aufwand
verbunden ist denn nicht nur der länder
muss zum mond geschickt werden sondern
auch ein mond satellit als relaisstation
um die signale an die erde zu senden
denn ein solcher länder kann von der
rückseite nicht direkt senden weil der
mond ja dazwischen ist das geht nur über
einen satelliten der von der erde aus
gesehen werden kann und vom länder quasi
über eck wird dann gesendet sie ist dort
im ewigen krater gelandet und nach der
landung ist der mondsonde etwas
bahnbrechendes gelungen ein
baumwollsamen ist aufgegangen dafür
wurde die luft in ein spezielles
gewächshaus der mondsonde extra mit co2
angereichert damit die pflanzen besser
wachsen können filter reinigen die luft
und uv lampen sterilisierten sie das
aufgehen der samen ist ein riesiger
erfolg denn es ist sehr schwierig die
bedingungen für wachstum von pflanzen
auf dem mond zu schaffen
doch wenige stunden später sind die
keimlinge dann bei minus 170 grad
celsius gefroren während der mond nacht
ist es dann eben doch zu kalt auf dem
erdtrabanten aber jetzt hat der rover
youtube zwei denn die sonde nach dem
touchdown verlassen hatte eine extrem
seltsame entdeckung gemacht eine
derartige seltsam gefärbte substanz der
rover fand die substanz am montag nach
der landung das mission steam entschied
sich den fahrplan für den rover zu
verschieben und stattdessen seine
instrumente darauf auszurichten
herauszufinden was das seltsame material
ist der montag acht begann am 25 juli
das pekinger kontrollzentrum für luft
und raumfahrt hatte für youtube zwei
einen pfad durch ein gebet
mit vielen kleinen einschlagskrater
eingeplant so steht es jedenfalls im
youtube zwei missions- tagebuch am 28
juni bereitete sich das schiff ihr team
darauf vor youtube 2 für sein übliches
mittagsschläfchen auszuschalten um den
rover vor hohen temperaturen und
sonneneinstrahlung zu schützen ein
teammitglied das bilder von der
hauptkamera des rovers überprüfte
entdeckte einen kleinen krater der
material zu enthalten schien das
antriebs team rief das mond
forschungsteam herbei gemeinsam
beschlossen den teams die pläne von
youtube zwei weiter nach westen zu
fahren zu verschieben und ließen den
rover das seltsame material untersucht
unterstützt von einer hindernis
vermeidungs kamera näherte sich youtube
zwei dem krater und zielte dann auf das
ungewöhnlich gefärbter material und
seine umgebung der rover untersuchte
beide bereiche mit seinem sichtbaren und
nahen infrarot spektrometer ams das
licht erkennt das von materialien
gestreut oder reflektiert wird um die
zusammensetzung zu analysieren bisher
haben die chinesischen forschungsteams
nichts über die ergebnisse verraten nur
eben dass sie derartig ist und eine
ungewöhnliche farbe hat eine mögliche
erklärung so die forscher ist dass es
sich bei der substanz um schmelz glas
handelt das aus meteoriten besteht die
auf die oberfläche des mondes
eingeschlagen sind wobei das wäre nicht
gelartige was wäre wenn der mond
verschwindet dieser frage gibt aston
comics tv nach anklicken anschauen auf
jeden fall und astro comics abonnieren
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran